c'est pour faire découvrir aux jeunes un
pan de l'environnement économique de la
martinique
vous savez que ce sont des jeunes qui ne
sortent pas beaucoup qui sont souvent
enfermés ils ont besoin de connaître
l'environnement dans lequel ils vivent
c'est à ce titre là que l'un d'entre eux
ayant proposé qu'on vienne au port nous
avons choisi d'amener d'autres avec nous
pour que ceux ci découvrent le port qui
est le poumon de la vie en martinique
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez susciter
chez eux justement à travers cette
visite
déjà qu'ils voient les choses qu'ils
aiment qu'ils ne connaissent pas
vous voyez découvrir simplement un
container pour eux c'est grandiose voir
déco camion comme lui il est au sens
vous voyez même bois vous voir vous qui
êtes à la télévision vous voir en vrai
pour eux c'est un grand bonheur vous
voyez c'est des petites choses mises
bout-à-bout qui leur apportent de la
joie et qui leur donne le sentiment et
la conviction qu'ils sont en vie que
cette société est aussi la leur